hey everybody and welcome to live coding
with Jessie today we're going to do some
styling of our our new react project
we're using a graph QL to get data from
WordPress and we just had a massive pool
request that I merged in a few hours ago
so let's briefly go through what's
changed from that pool request you can
check it out at the repo there's a link
in the description
it'll be pool request number two okay
it's already closed cuz it's been merged
but you can check that out if you want
to look through the files on your own
I'm just gonna kind of try to summarize
it because it's it's quite large so
definitely it would take a long time to
go through all the lines that have
changed so so Harshit submitted this
request basically it merged what he had
done in pool request one which we did go
over last week so he just closed pool
request one and then added all the
changes into two so in addition to the
things that were added before now
material UI the beta version of material
you are the newer version that we were
trying to get working on friday is now
working it's all set up there's a layout
component let me show you what it looks
like as I'm describing it so here we go
so he he actually set up a temporary
WordPress installation to grab data from
so now actually I am
I pulled I had an old test install of
WordPress that I hadn't really been
using for anything so I just pulled it
in it just has some well it has bacon
ipsum so instead of lorem ipsum it has
the names of different cuts of meat and
i grabbed some of these images from
so that's like the big picture what's
changed there's so much more so I
definitely recommend if you really want
to understand what changed go through
some of the at least some of the pool
requests to see and you know line by
line what did change I've made some
changes in addition to that so harsh its
API had for every post there was an
image but mine didn't so initially when
I tried to pull things in it didn't work
I was getting an error so I just simply
added in a check to see if there was an
image and if there was then we try to
render the image if not we don't try to
render the image at all so in this case
we actually don't even we don't even
render this whole section of the card so
you'll see in a second if you're not
familiar with with this particular
component and material UI it would try
to render it basically be a big blank
area so we just completely pulled that
out so I'll show you that now I think
it's in the post detail is it no post
preview that's what it is because you
can see there's there's a lot more
components in here than there were last
week let's see oh here it is
okay so we just did this basically we're
just checking to see if an image URL has
been passed in from the parent component
and then if not we don't do anything if
there is one then we we render it and I
believe the parent component would be
here yeah so in the parent component we
do a check to see if there was an image
see so we're either passing in or not
passing in the the image URL all right
so that's I mean that's basically it
I other than setting up the graph QL
plug-in on the old WordPress
installation and updating some other
plugins that's that's pretty much all
that was done so let's see let's go to
say that's all that was done by me I
should clarify let's I do want to start
it's not not CSS let's start with our
app is and no it's not there oh sorry
layout I wanted to start from what we're
first bringing in material material UI
so you can see we have a layout
component now and that's what we're
importing a bunch of stuff from material
UI and then we have some some styles in
line here I shouldn't say in line but in
in component Styles
all right and then here's where we have
like our app bar and ice were and our
title right so this is these are things
that every page needs here we go here's
our drawer so that side that side
navigation drawer here that's also in
the layout and control here so what wind
up doing is will list out the categories
here as well see and then this is where
we pull in the content from the views so
let's check out well let's check out our
home view now what this looks like
let's see so we're pulling in layout
everything is wrapped in layout now so
everything that was in layout is going
to get applied we also have helmet so
react helmet and this allows us to
change the title rank is normally within
a component we don't have access to the
stuff that's in the you know in the top
of the HTML document but with helmet we
do have access to it and we actually can
do at some point up we could probably
even move this to the layout component
and pass in a prop for the title if we
wanted to clean it up even more it's not
really a big thing but it might save us
a few lines so we'd save a line of code
up here and a few down here so we may
end up doing that all right so maybe
that's that's basically it you know we
see the post detail page is the same
thing laid out the same way category
page right now lists it out posts like
those for category one but wind up
having when we actually hook up the real
data for this we're gonna have so many
posts that it'll be way too many to put
on the page like this so I mean this
works it works for now but we have I
think we definitely have hundreds of
posts already so we'll have the
categories listed on the side and then
when you click a category it'll have
each page will be like a single category
page but this looks I mean this is
pretty amazing
how much Harshit got done and just a day
or two so thank you so much for that
this gives us like a huge jump start so
yeah and I did I just checked a lot chat
now I see harsh it mentioned downgrading
WP graphic you also in fact I did we had
a little bit of discussion on Friday
about it hard
recommended downgrading I really kind of
wanted to see like what could I make the
latest version work and right after the
stream I I spent a little bit of time
checking it out and I just I decided to
go with harsha's advice and just
downgrade and that it worked so for now
we're gonna do it like that
later on I don't know we'll see I
actually may want to have the
authentication but right now since we're
just testing I really don't want to add
in that whole extra element of
complexity and having to use like JSON
web tokens or something that's just
gonna it I feel like at this point I
want to get it developed out more you
know kind of tangibly what we can see
and then we can tackle the
authentication I'm still I still need to
get in contact with someone about the
single sign-on and see you know what
what that's gonna involve and
integrating that with our project so
there's just too many things I don't
know yet about how that's gonna work so
we're just gonna put that off until
later on okay I'm just checking the live
chat briefly see if there's anything I
should respond to right now okay all
right also harsh it reminded me to start
the end Rock server so I'm starting that
right now and I will copy the link in so
if you're not familiar with the end rock
server this basically lets you all test
out what I have here that I'm running on
localhost
so if you click the link that I just
pasted it in the live chat you can see
this you can inspect it you can use your
dev tools so if you have react installed
with your chrome dev tools you'll be
able to see that if you have the dev
tools that you use with graph QL you can
see that it even responds to
the Redux dev tools as well because
Redux is going you know doing its thing
behind the scenes of Apollo so I mean
not it's a little bit different than
you'd normally see in react state right
because there's I mean Apollo
understands what's going on but it's not
really like friendly for people to read
quite as much as if you'd make your own
store but you can go in here to apollo
stuff and check all this stuff out check
out your queries so it's kind of nice
because then it could be more
interactive you could actually you know
check out what's going on in real time
okay so here's what we're gonna do today
I know that was kind of a long intro
uh-huh it's like um like a 15-minute
intro but we had a significant pool
request so I definitely needed needed to
go over that some of those changes so
here's what we want to do we definitely
need to change the color scheme to match
the university color scheme we'll
probably add the University logo in here
somewhere
maybe up here we'll see we'll see it
makes the most sense and we're gonna
change up the other the homepage here so
let's try to get the categories listed
down the side and this you this is
actually perfect the size and everything
but we I also want some other view
options available so we can simply get
some icons over here so the users can
select some of the other options would
you see how it's going I'd like to get
to Pomodoro sessions in if I can but
since I'm starting my first session so
far into the stream we'll just have to
see how it goes I have a meeting coming
up in about an hour so I don't want to
be late for that when the the head of my
department will be in the meeting so
definitely don't want to mess around and
I I need to get a little bit of data to
present at that meeting so it will be a
shorter stream than normal but hopefully
we can get something useful in so I'm
gonna stop talking about about this and
I get to the stream let's see
all right so we should probably check
the documentation for material UI first
and I guess the first thing we could do
that will hopefully be pretty easy is
just change some of the colors so
actually not now that I think about it I
don't think we need to check the
documentation since we have in the
layout page we have a lot of styles here
it's probably here somewhere so let's
just check it out
there'd be color here the only color
thing I see here is this background
color but looks like that's for the
content so let's make sure
all right so we will check out the
documentation so probably probably
themed you see how we're bringing this
in
I just list the live chat and Brett said
this demo is making me hungry yeah I
[Music]
actually just got off the phone with
tech support for Google Phi and the
woman on tech support was super nice and
she was telling me about what she had
for lunch
and she made this pasta with alfredo
sauce from scratch she's telling me how
she made it with heavy cream and stuff
I'm like I have anybody who's vegetarian
or vegan I'm not trying to upset you
if it is really offensive to somebody
let me know I can change it up but this
was just what I already had in here from
a while ago so I know my brother's a
vegan so I guess I'm I have to think
about that all the time now in case if
he's going to be over I can't put meat
in anything all right okay so what
Dorothy wants I don't think we're set up
right now with a theme
right
we're not pulling that in that would
probably be the way we want to go Oh
actually no we are pulling maybe I'm
just missing it
let's see
haha Bret says there's not a vegan ipsum
yet alright
okay so in case in case you're not
following what's what I'm trying to do
here I was basically looking for if we
had pulled in something like this from
materialized styles but it looks like
we're pulling in with styles from
material us styles so
I'm not sure I'm not sure if we could
change these I guess we could try
hmmm alright so I was looking for
something that was matching up with what
we were already changing it here
all right so
let's let's keep looking a little bit
yes we could try to override I'd rather
not override for the for the colors
because you know we're gonna have a
certain color palette that we want to be
applied throughout
mmm
you know see if it says something
no bus not only I thought we were gonna
start out with something easy and it
turns out it's not so easy okay well
then let's let's just start here with
this theme then and maybe we'll
implement this
okay
all right so actually so hard should is
saying theme is the right way to do it
so just just for me so I'm clear Harshit
so do you mean should we go with adding
this in and wrapping everything in this
Mui theme provider or are you saying
that basically what we have going on
here is sufficient and I can just add
into this and it would it would work
okay so 1010 damer says you should wrap
your app in the Mui theme provider
Harshit says theme okay so this will
apply throughout
okay I'm getting I'm getting it seems
like conflicting advice here
I guess that for now let's just try to
put in something into the the current
theme object and see if it'll change
some stuff so let's just copy I want to
find somewhere there we go
primary so I'd like to take all right
this is nested and so I'm gonna take
this palette which trying to find where
it ends but it just is not ending all
right let me let me just move this to
the other screen and I'll just type it
out of it all right so let's see
instead of steam
Opa le TT and primary
the primary and goodness
I really would rather not have to
manually put all these in for now let's
see
-
she said it people that I can't remember
with that hex color is no-limit
execution
forget the comma straighten up
all right nothing changed a big change
from that I mean you think that'd be the
primary color right
okay all right so now ours just saying
we could import so let's import this
now should I also import with styles or
are we gonna get rid of that and replace
it with with some of this let's rap
let's wrap everything in that
what did i do i okay i messed up on the
capitalization there we go alright let's
see
okay so harsh it's pasting in some some
code for me here so let me put this in
okay all right so now let's just bring
this in
see ok well it didn't change that but we
didn't get errors so I guess that's ok
so case for now alright so now let's see
woods
who
okay I did not put the theme in down
here thanks ah [ __ ] if you're just
joining you didn't see the beginning so
a hard [ __ ] submitted a pool request
over the weekend that implemented this
material UI v1 and so that's why I'm
getting a lot of advice from him because
I didn't I didn't implement this so I'm
just trying to learn as we go and while
I'm not normally an expert at things I'm
usually not quite this clueless but I'm
benefiting greatly from from Harsha in
this stream yeah all right it works
great
alright so already over a half hour into
the stream and we got our first thing to
work okay awesome so now at least we
know that this is set up in a way that
you know we can go ahead and change a
lot of things in our theme like this
obviously I wouldn't want every one of
these values to be green but I don't
want to try to calculate this on my own
I'll probably try to find I'm sure
there's some material design calculator
where I can pop in the base color and
it'll produce all these for me so
alright so we have the color in here
that was that was step one that's what
we wanted to do first so let's do some
shree do let's see if we can put in a
logo and maybe some of our some icons up
here so we haven't tried to deal with
icons yet in this new version of
material UI so maybe we can figure out
how to do that let's figure out how to
do that first since that's kind of new I
mean put an image in is probably not
going to be that hard this is kind of
basic let's see oops so I guess we're
good in the app bar component so let's
check this out
and off I'm looking for where the
material ID documentation is I moved it
over on the other screen also I just
remembered that I'm blocking my timer so
you all can't see it with my hat with my
face okay let's see so we want the
components and the app bar and I guess
we'll want to check that bar with
buttons yep so we I mean we don't
exactly want a button we want to put
icons there but it should be similar
there we go I think if we just put an
icon button
biography
yeah let's just try to throw an icon
button over there and see what it does
so we'll need to bring in let's bring in
the icon button first we need the icon
button actually we need the the icons as
well so we don't we don't want the menu
icon and want some other icons
but actually we're already pulling that
in so I didn't check first and instead
of the menu icon
I want this there's got to be some type
of reference for all the icons so let's
see where they talk about the icons
let's see if they list the icons
okay so I'm guess if I just look them up
at the regular materiai Khan's place
then the names will be the same so I
don't want that
what is it came out what it's called
what's the what's this called word has
the three dots vertical that's what I
want
let's go
I know it has to be in here because you
see it on google apps all the time and
see
the lips all right let me try to type in
some of these it's not that
I probably have it downloaded somewhere
Mike the SVG version already I should
just check my downloads folder there we
go
Wow okay more alright that's what it's
called so I'm guessing I can just type
more vert and it will work let's try
that mmm what's project I've type in
more vert icon
maybe we'll see maybe it'll work
alright so let's grab this should have a
icon button and put it in down here
where our not there we want the app bar
or is there a bar bar
okay so we'll win it after no before
toolbar yeah we want it before toolbar
but after typography so I don't want it
to have the class a mini but we'll
probably want to put some Styles on it
at some point but for now let's take
that out and it's not say more for now
and more birds so now let's see if that
word
Hey okay so it kind of worked so we did
get we got this in here it works it's
just on this side so let's see how they
did it here probably they have some type
of styling they call this one for the
login button
I think they used to flex one on this I
don't think we're using flex one on that
we'll check it out sort of typography
flex all right let's check out our theme
here and see if we have a flex class if
not we'll add it now I don't think we
did
all right let's add a flex class up here
and in our our flex class we just want
to say flex one all right so this is
it's basically gonna make it take up the
take up the space as much space as it as
it can in this container and who else
actually isn't John Hanson is pretty
good about flex box stuff so if he's
watching I don't think I've seen him but
if he's watching you can correct my my
flex box and all this year and oh I
didn't I didn't actually add that on to
the component so let's do that so down
here we're going to add a class name of
classes oops that's not we have a what
did we call it do we call it classes I
guess we did classes flex
there we go okay so now we have it over
here on the side awesome cool we even
got a nice little click effect there
great okay so I'm learning a lot more
about using flex because I'm doing some
react native stuff for my Udacity course
and I guess when you're doing react
native you have to do everything with
flex you can't use like other CSS
positioning things and so yeah so that's
cool all right so we have that icon here
for now I'm cool with this icon we'll
probably want to add some more icons
let me show it's been a while I think
since I've shown what we're what we're
trying to upgrade so let me make sure
there's nothing so this is like a
private site so as long as there's
nothing that can't be public here yeah I
think we're good so let me show this so
right now this is what we're going off
of so you can see you know you get we
have this week's bulletin up here we
have some menu icons so we have
different views we have a print view we
have a view that's like a grid so it
looks more like Pinterest and we can
search so we'll have some icons up here
a few more icons and then we have our
categories here and we also have some
filters and we have another another view
type down here at classic mode and we'll
have we have a submit announcement form
so that's what we're gonna end up having
in here and so depending on depending on
how things go and how much time we have
I wouldn't like my times up here we'll
do five minutes of question answer but
depending on how it goes I would like to
maybe give the user some more control
over
the options of what view do they want to
show by default things like that maybe
giving the ability to like star certain
things or bookmark them and save them
for later so they'll have their own
section of you know like maybe
bookmarked announcements but that does
kind of depend on what happens with the
single sign-on and and how that all
works right now with the way I'm signing
users on I could store data and get that
for users but since that may change in
the near future I'm not really gonna do
anything with it right now so let's do a
short break
check the time okay so we'll see we
might not get that much more done
actually because I didn't realize my
time are you gone off and I I think that
went over a lot for that Pomodoro
session so yeah we'll see we we might
not do another session which is very
abnormal usually at least do two but I
do want to make sure I can get oops
where's my I was trying to get my
comments up on my other screen so okay
I'm gonna scroll way up to the talks I
haven't really gone through the comments
very much at all and I'm gonna go down
through and try to answer as many
questions as I can see
okay Jase laces materialise one of the
worst web front-end frameworks ever okay
it says semantic UI it's one that I've
been using heavily lately has a lot of
nice API integrations to handle
populating forms and such check chicken
Jase laces granted I haven't used
material on about six months it was
really difficult to use properly as a
lot of things we're not working this may
have changed since okay yeah well I I
haven't really used a lot of different
UI frameworks for react so we did use
the old version of material UI for the
last project and this is the latest
version so I imagine there is a lot that
has changed in the last six months at
least with the latest version the old
version is probably pretty similar to
what it was so I'm very much still
learning it I like it because it uses
the material design and that's so that
helps me out if I'd used if I use
another framework I would have to spend
more time styling it differently than
the default styles to make it look more
like the material design style that that
we use here at the University for other
side projects it wouldn't be a problem
but that's why we're going to tear UI
now there are a few other material
design frameworks out there so I'm open
to trying them as well but you know if
this works out at some point I'd like to
just stick with one and get really good
at it right now I'm still kind of in the
phase where I'm searching for one that I
really like so yeah any suggestions are
definitely welcome
um Mohammad Reza says hi Jesse this is
my first time watching you online hey
how's it going thanks so much for
watching I'm glad you could catch me
live yeah feel free to ask any questions
or comment and I'll try to try to answer
any questions yet oh cool so Bret Bret
says Bret was having a conversation
about learning react but I just want to
read one of the comments out because
it's flattering to me Bret says I was
struggling to learn react until I
started free code camp and built a site
using Jesse's first react project that's
really cool I always like whenever
you'll let me know that you've used some
stuff that we've done on the stream in
your own projects I'd love to look at
that stuff so if anyone has done
anything like that definitely you know
send me a link to the github repo or if
it's live somewhere online you know
definitely like to check it out and I'm
really busy lately because of my other
course that's going on so I've been
slacking on this but I do like to give
feedback Lee if you have a project and
you want you want me to take a look at
it and you tell you what I think I'm
definitely down to do that just you know
for those of you have done it if I
haven't gotten back to you yet I am
really sorry I have not forgotten about
you but I've just been working a lot you
know if I have free time at home to work
then I'm working on my my course so that
should be over by the end of this month
and then I'll have a little bit more
time okay
all right so my five-minute timer is up
for questions and answers yeah I think I
think I'm not gonna do another point
Medora session I'm just gonna do Q&A cuz
I'm scrolling through and I'm not even
halfway through the live chat so I don't
think there's any way that I could do
another session and get through the chat
and still be able to look up the date I
need for my meeting so yeah so we're
just going to do question and answer so
I hope to get a little bit more done I
kind of got tripped up a little bit at
the beginning and and trying to
implement this theme but we got it
working now and I mean it's in place you
could pretty much do whatever you want
with the theme now we did get this
working which that was easier than I
thought so
yeah so I guess tomorrow we'll do some
more us stuff we'll get the logo and
we'll work on maybe some of the
different views maybe you get that like
grid view layout and get some categories
in here so it'll start looking more like
it's it's actually going to look and
then we can then we can tackle some more
than behind the scenes thing like
pulling in some more data we're
definitely going to need we're gonna
need some custom fields and make sure we
can pull those and from the graph QL API
so and then we're gonna figure out you
know how do we display those to the user
we're gonna have to hook up a form which
we've done before but we're gonna have
to do that again which means we're going
to need a custom server so we'll do
server Jas file so there's a lot of
stuff stuff that we have done before but
we're doing again and we'll try I always
like to try to do it better you know
each time so maybe we can try out some
new stuff or you know whatever we need
to do file uploads so there's definitely
some some cool stuff they don't need
done and then the big thing at least in
my mind because I'm not sure how it's
gonna work out is going to be the the
login and potentially authentication for
our our graph QL API so that'll be fun
learn a lot from that and hopefully you
all can learn from it or help me learn
from it
okay so that's the plan coming up I just
want to tell you all just so you know
like whether it's worth your time to
watch or if if you're really good at
something like that you know if maybe
you'll want to do a pull request or
something like that so anyway that's the
plan for now let me keep going through
the questions in the live chat if you do
have a question put it in there now I
think I will have time to get through
all the questions and if you don't have
a question please stick around the and
help answer some questions cuz I
definitely don't know enough to handle
all the questions
okay so Blake has a question does graph
QL take posts and content from a
wordpress site and poured it into the
react website okay so Brett responds to
this saying it runs queries on the API
in this case the WordPress REST API yeah
okay so I haven't looked into exactly
what the graph QL plug-in that we're
using does but it seems so Brett saying
that it actually uses the WordPress REST
API to get the data initially okay which
that's kind of cool
and then it then it sends the data so it
works just like we were using the REST
API in previous projects so we are I
mean let me see lakes initial questions
answer this correctly
okay so I wouldn't say I wouldn't put it
like that that graph QL imports them in
so you have graph QL basically working
on the WordPress side of things so
that's your API so before where we were
calling the REST API and getting data
now we're calling this graph QL API and
getting getting data then so we make a
call basically using before where we
were using fetch now we're using Apollo
to make the call I mean I it's it's
probably not an exact comparison there
but basically it's the serving the same
purpose so we're using Apollo to make
the call and get the data then once we
have it in there Apollo does some stuff
behind the scenes with Redux so you
basically have the equivalent of a store
that's available wherever you need it
and that's how we get the data
so hopefully that made sense in terms of
how how that all those things interact
with each other
Mohamed's would like to know the best UI
websites for making a website trying to
see if there are some answers here
alright so uh
Mohammed it so first of all it depends
on whether you're using react or not so
if you are using react and I recommend
specifically a UI library that works
with reacted as react components so if
you're in a material design material UI
either the original version or the new
version one beta will work there are a
few other material design libraries for
react I haven't had that much experience
with them and then there are also some
other things I'm pretty sure there's at
least one bootstrap library for react so
if you're familiar with using bootstrap
and other sites I assume it works in a
similar way if you're not using react
and you're making you know some other
type of HTML CSS you know JavaScript
site then you could use again if you
like material design you could use
materialized you could use bootstrap
which is very common foundation there's
another good one we had a recommendation
earlier from Jay slay to use semantic UI
so those are just some of my suggestions
of things that I've either used myself
or I've seen other people use heard good
things about so I don't know that
there's one that I could say for sure
this is the best one because it
definitely depends on what what look
you're going for with your site right if
you really want a material design then I
don't recommend using a library that's
not material design it could work but
you'll spend a lot more time customizing
it in the same way if you if you don't
want material design look then don't use
material eyes or material UI and I
noticed a little bit further up by miss
Jason Leia says I'm having trouble
finding a good use case for react
there's a lot of my projects are really
small one-off things so I would say if
you are trying to learn react then it's
worth it to even do small projects that
don't necessarily need react because
those small simple projects will help
you learn react if you're doing a big
project that's more complicated there's
a lot of other things that aren't even
necessarily react things that you'll
probably have to figure out and so it'll
just add to the difficulty and make it
it'll make it harder to learn so I
recommend you know do some stuff with
reacts it's really small stuff it'll
just get you used to doing certain
things you know the react way so if you
can if you have the freedom to be able
to use react for that I know if it's if
it's projects for a client or for where
you work you don't always have the
ability to pick you know what you're
going to use but if it's a side project
and you can pick then then I definitely
recommend doing that and don't worry so
much about it's too small you know for
react like you're trying to learn it so
it's probably better than small mm-hmm
sorry yawning again I don't know what
this is our last week I just kept
yawning during the stream all the time
I I got enough sleep I should not be
yawning but oh well I hope I'm not
making all of you yawn all right let's
see
and the Resource Center you forgot that
yeah
I thought we used that for the Resource
Center
but I wasn't sure if it still worked in
the same way for this version and to be
honest with you I'm pretty sure it might
have been Sebastian that got that
working on the resource centers so this
is two projects in a row that we've used
material UI and I haven't actually set
it up myself yet I'm very very grateful
for all the help that you give me on
here so that probably explains why I am
I still had to look everything up
because I in fact have never done it
even though we used it on the last
project the good thing about that though
is you set it you set it up once the
beginning of the project and then you
don't have to set it up again so after
that it's much easier to use
okay so blake is asking like so Blake
asks a question about graph QL saying so
Blake said but if I designed a website
with HTML react somebody else could
write the posts and images and it would
automatically add to my website yeah
yeah that's exactly how it works yeah so
if I were to go into the WordPress
actually let me bring this over I'll
just demonstrate it so here I am and
this is the WordPress installation for
this I can go into posts and let's add a
new post and let's just say
okay does publish that and see how
quickly we can get it to show up we
might have to refresh Oh we'll see it's
already there so somebody could have the
login info to get in here and edit these
posts and have no access at all to this
and they could add data and then it
would it would show up here and in fact
that's the setup that we're going to
have for this once this goes live our
someone actually more than one person in
my department will have access to this
they will be in charge of putting all
the content in and then it will display
here and at that point I'm really only
involved if something goes wrong or if
it doesn't show up right so that's
actually why I'm using WordPress for the
content for this so that someone who
doesn't know about the code can edit
posts easily okay so Brett's saying we
were talking earlier about using react
for small projects Brett says the small
things are hard to justify using react
but Jesse's first project actually uses
jQuery a lot and I've been mixing the
two a bit getting something to work in
jQuery then moving it to react yeah
actually I forgot we did do that so we
have yes so that first project we build
it out as a non reacts it-- first then
we converted it to react I forgot that
we did that yes so we basically had that
we had a back-up plan because initially
the deadline was really short and then
we ended up being able to launch the
site a little bit later which was nice
because the site ended up being a lot
better you know once we had some more
time to work on it but the initial plan
was if we couldn't get the react site
working then it was faster to just use
the just kind of build it out using
jQuery and we used materialized CSS so
yes that's actually kind of a fun
exercise to to take an existing site but
with something else and then convert it
to react so that that was fun I liked
that it was odd now that I go back and
look at the code and I see that I'm
mixing jQuery with things I think I
definitely wouldn't have done it like
that now but at the time that that
allowed us to get the site up and
running as quickly as we did it would
definitely took longer than I
anticipated but we had a lot of changes
that were not anticipated as well so if
it would have been based on initially
what we're gonna do for the site it
definitely could have been done a lot
faster
Martin asks do you not use semicolons
and JavaScript anymore it's it's a
choice right so you don't have to so if
you want to use semicolons that's
totally that's fine some people's really
say you should use semicolons but
they're pretty much optional there's I
think at least one use case where you
are supposed to use semicolons because
it might mess things up if you don't I
can't remember offhand what that use
case is I remember looking it up just to
make sure and it was a use case that I I
don't know that I've ever even come
across personally so that's why I don't
use semicolons I have like automatic
formatting set up with prettier and
standard J s and I have it set to remove
all semicolons so that's just how I like
to do things for me if if you have two
pieces of code and one is shorter than
the other piece of code but they do the
exactly the same thing then I'm going to
go with the shorter piece of code you
know normally that's that's what I'll go
with so removing all the semicolons
overall makes less code right so that's
why I like it just one less thing to
have to type but it's it's it's
definitely your choice
it's theirs if someone has in the live
chat as the handle google sucks I'm just
gonna call them Google for right now
says this can't be totally free what's
the catch
what do you mean totally free like free
code camp being free or what if it's
free code can that yeah it is it's
entirely free because like everybody's
volunteered so there's a lot of people
that contribute their time to make all
the different things that free code camp
does happen so that's why I can it can
be free because of everyone you know
everyone making pull requests for things
and there's just there's so many people
working on things so that's how it's
that's how it's free so thanks everybody
I who helps out with free code camp
there's a lot I mean I I do my little
thing here on YouTube but there are so
many people who have contributed so much
you know for so long so it definitely if
you can contribute I definitely consider
doing that because that would be awesome
and it would keep free code camp going
cool Brett says this is great you can
have one theme and use it for several
projects yeah yeah actually that's
that's why when I said earlier like I'd
like to just pick one thing and keep
using it that's the big benefit of doing
that is like let's say I decide I want
to keep using this version of material
UI I could we could make our theme here
set all our colors how we want things to
be and then just for our next project we
can just copy that over and it will all
work and we won't have to do that step
again so it would definitely save some
time
Oh Harshit says by the way I'm only 15
years old never worked on a big project
well honestly Archie that is I'm super
impressed that you're 15 and you're able
to do all this so quickly - I mean no
like I said earlier check out the pool
request number - and everything that
Harsha did so much stuff and this was
all over the course of I don't know two
days maybe three days it seemed it
really is really awesome so I'm
definitely impressed yeah like keep it
up I mean you uh I think you'll be a
great programmer if you keep you know
keep working at it because you're
already awesome
and Bret says too harsh it's is Europe
you are a confident developer at fifteen
just imagine what you'll be doing at
thirty hardsuits is up studying science
right now at high school physics and
math
cool yeah that's I don't know how it is
where you're at I'm not I don't know
where you're located at Harshit but from
where I am physics and math were always
like the hardest subjects to study in in
high school so you must be pretty smart
yes so I'm actually I'm really glad that
you were contributing my project cuz I
think one day down the road you'll
probably be doing really awesome things
and I'll be able to say like hey I
worked on a project with that guy you
know back in the day but that's awesome
I wish I was more productive when I was
15 I definitely was not doing anything
as awesome as contributing open-source
react projects and well there YouTube
didn't exist when I was 15 so I couldn't
couldn't have been on YouTube
oh cool it looks like so Robert said
that harsh it has some nice YouTube
videos on his YouTube channel so I'll
have to check those out when I get a
chance so yeah definitely if you'd like
to see what you're working on
kinda 808 says hello everyone hey how's
it going thanks for watching
see
I got some reason my lab chest skipped
all the way down to the bottom so now I
lost my place here all right I'm left to
kind of go quickly through the rest of
this because I'm coming up close to my
meeting time here okay so it looks like
we have somebody in here as the name of
someone who's famous so I'm not sure I
didn't look it up I'm not gonna look it
up just cuz I'm running out of time but
may or may not actually be someone
famous
okay alright so I guess he's the vice
president of the Indian opposition not
not probably not the guy that's in the
channel right now but that does the same
name he had definitely not the same guy
all right cool well anyway welcome Rahul
thanks for watching
okay I'm gonna try to pronounce his name
I'm apologizing in advance if I get it
wrong and a new low wopo and a new low
I'm sorry I'm so hopefully you know I'm
talking about that says testing
components built with material is
extremely difficult okay hmm I'll have
to have to keep that in mind as anybody
else have experience testing material I
components I definitely want to use some
some type of testing if we can on this
project so at this point I'm probably
gonna keep going with materiai but I
would like to know if anybody is has
experience successfully testing things
let's see no beer says Jessie where do
you host your website dot IO domain
that's what I'm talking about
I do I have a dot IO
I don't know it's just I don't know
which website any toilet so my my
personal website against this
professional website is Jesse Weibull
calm I don't currently have an IO
actually be cool to have an IO maybe I
should get one world's asked do most UI
frameworks work with react you can make
them work with reacts but the ones that
actually have react components I think
are better so I try to deal with those
I've made materialized CSS is not a
react framework but I did make it work
in project one you just have to be
careful with some of the jQuery stuff
you you don't you really want to try not
to manipulate the Dom because it messes
with with what react does so it can work
but it's not ideal but if you do want to
make it work check out project one on
this YouTube channel and on the live
it'll be on the live coding with Jesse
playlist yeah so check out the first
project that we did and I mean that's an
example of getting a non reacting work
to work with with react
Hamza says was was it the first project
when you set up lint stage and prettier
or the second um I don't know let's just
check
oops I meant to take github
[Music]
no no that's not it I once see I reacts
nuts yes static there we go yeah yeah
for the first project that's we did have
lint stage and fruitier setup on that
one no beer says I heard that react plus
Redux equals powerful yeah yeah
definitely
we were actually gonna use Redux for
this project but then realized that we
didn't have to use Redux and that's what
Harshit had removed Redux and replaced
it with all the Apollo stuff but we'll
probably end up using Redux at some
point for another project so I just used
it for another project that I did for
that Udacity course and it is really
cool it was a little bit difficult to
you know figure it all out at first but
once I got the hang of it
I could definitely see like how useful
it is harsh it's asks about a link for
the slack Channel
I don't currently have a link for the
slack Channel that works there's a
workaround that I need to work on I just
haven't had time to get a setup yet so
if I guess for now if you really want to
get in the slack channel before I get
the workaround set up send me a message
on Twitter with your email and I can
send you a an invite to your email I
don't know if I could get you the invite
today cuz I'm gonna be pretty busy the
rest of the day but probably tomorrow
okay Arshad says there's also been some
changes made in the graph QL folder with
fragments so yeah I'm betting animals
time visit all right I'm gonna have to
check that out later okay but I'm gonna
leave this open so I don't forget to
look at it I'm just going to check I'm
not gonna read all the comments cuz run
out of time here but I'm gonna check for
questions so if I don't read your
comment I'm sorry just running out of at
a time here
Oh actually I'm going to read this this
sounds useful Brett says you can make
you material UI theme a separate get
repo and imported for each project that
sounds but that sounds really good I
love that idea
Robert says have you used material UI
with routing in a react project that's
the point regular stuck yeah so we have
used react router with material UI the
the last project that we did well I
guess not the last one project to so
project 2 is the the Resource Center we
use material I and react router we add
some routing going on there so check
that out maybe hopefully that can help
and if you have any questions let me
know
okay so the name before that I have
trouble pronouncing he says you can call
me I know so
all right I'll I'll try remember to call
you a new and start really sorry about
that I do try to pronounce everyone's
name properly if at all possible
oh okay so earlier nobody was asking
about the dot IO site and that's the N
grog site so that's a it's it's the
thing you run I'm running it on my
computer it basically takes whatever I'm
running with on localhost and it
converts it into a live URL that people
can go to to check it out so normally
you can't have this many people on and
rock looking like by default from the
free plan but the guy that's that runs
and grukk he is letting us use it for
free for free code camp stream so very
generous very generous of him so anyway
that's why you know you all can see that
so it's not like my site personally it's
through and grow
all right so one more question and then
I have to go I'm getting some slack
messages from my boss so Angela says
have you tried to test material I
component a fool Dom with just an enzyme
okay what did we do on the we had some
testing going on with material UI on
project 2 so I mean if you want to check
out some of the videos from project to
the or even check out the repo for
project 2 that was the the Resource
Center we did have we usually materiai
we did have some testing going on so
maybe that'll have something useful for
you on there but alright so at this
point I definitely have to go thanks so
much for all your help and for all the
contributions here in the live chat I
will be back tomorrow and until then
have a great day